hello readers how do we know what is
true and what isn't
my mama always told me don't believe
everything you read
just because someone took the time to
write something down send it off to be
typeset and designed and printed in a
book or published on the internet
doesn't mean they bothered to tell you
the truth you should be skeptical of all
informational writing until the writer
gives you a reason to trust them
honestly you should be skeptical of me
until i give you a reason to trust me
who am i after all just some stranger on
the internet
well that's a little unfair actually you
probably knew about khan academy well
before you watched this video which
means you have a sense that the
information we teach is reputable or
trustworthy
so maybe i'm already at an advantage for
you trustworthiness wise because you
associate me with an institution you
already have good feelings about
when an author writes for informational
purposes they want you to believe that
they're telling the truth but you can't
just accept that on faith
no human being is so important that they
can't be bothered to explain themselves
now let's be clear that doesn't mean
that everyone you disagree with
personally owes you an explanation it
just means that you don't have to
swallow their arguments hook line and
sinker
so how do we move forward we can't just
go around in a nightmarish swirl of
misinformation never knowing whom to
trust that's not good society couldn't
function imagine looking at the weather
report and saying i don't believe you
and then walking outside your home in
shorts when the forecast calls for snow
that would be terrible
for you
the key is to ask yourself why should
you trust the weather forecast
well forecasters are scientists
specifically meteorologists their job is
to study weather patterns and make
predictions and that doesn't mean they
always get it right because they're
making what amounts to educated guesses
about the weather but their expertise
and their access to weather monitoring
equipment make them likelier to know
what the weather is going to do than the
average person would
and this is basically the test you
should bring to all informational
writing
good readers look for clues to establish
trustworthiness to establish that the
author knows what they're talking about
that they've done their research that
they're an expert worth listening to
someone who hops on youtube and says
here's why your teachers are lying to
you about the goblins who live in the
moon is someone that warrants some
skepticism a little side eye also how
awesome would it be if there were moon
goblins and why would anyone want that
information to be kept secret okay when
you look at a text you have to wrap your
head around three big things one the
main idea or the claim
what is the author trying to say explain
or convince you of
two
the evidence for that claim
what are the facts details or other
pieces of information that tell us that
that claim is true or accurate
and three the reasoning
how does the evidence prove that the
claim is true
okay so let's imagine that this
conspiracy guy on youtube is trying to
make the case about those goblins
let's listen in on his argument
i firmly believe that there is a colony
of goblins living inside the moon and
the government is keeping this
information from you how do we know this
look at the moon see that little
squiggle you were taught that was just a
crater but it isn't it's actually the
tip of an enormous goblin moon base how
do i know that the goblins told me so i
have a special phone line from my house
to the moon goblins and through me they
can answer any questions you've got
our moon door is always open the goblins
tell me
all right so what's the claim
goblins live inside the moon
what's his proof
what we think is a crater on the moon is
actually a goblin moon base
what's his reasoning what backs that up
he says the goblins told him so now is
that evidence or is that just something
he's telling us well one way we can know
he's probably full of baloney is that
only he can talk to the moon goblins
right he says he's got a special phone
line
they can answer questions through him
we can't talk to the goblins we we can't
have access to any of their information
he's behaving like the information is
freely out there for anyone but it isn't
you have to go through him
so can the stuff he's saying be
independently verified that is to say
can anyone other than this person prove
that there are moon goblins or that that
crater is a moon base
are there photos or video from those
goblins and if not why not this doesn't
pass the smell test for me
there's proof but only i get to see it
is not proof that's just made up
when it comes to making arguments you
have to show your work
a good writer has to earn the trust of
their audience and a good reader has to
make a writer work for that trust what
does that look like i hear you asking
excellent question let's take a look at
a piece that does its homework
okay let's read there are some
conspiracy theorists that claim that
nasa's moon landing missions in the late
60s and 70s never happened despite the
mountain of evidence to the contrary
they claimed that the photographs were
faked the mission recordings were
scripted and the moon rocks were nothing
more than ordinary earth rocks perhaps
you are among these conspiracists if so
let me prove to you that the moon
landings took place
perhaps you are skeptical of the us
government which was in the middle of
the cold war with the soviet union and a
shooting war in vietnam perhaps you
believe that any information from nasa
is therefore suspicious
fortunately for you there is plenty of
third-party evidence that americans
traveled to and landed on the moon
an observatory in the uk that previously
observed the russian launch of the
sputnik probe used its radio telescope
to observe the 1969 moon landing
the bochum observatory this one in
germany also confirms that mission
finally present day photos from many
different space agencies around the
world have confirmed the presence of
footprints rover tracks and the lunar
rovers themselves
in order for a moon landing to have been
faked the rocket scientist james michael
lungusky estimates that more than 400
000 people who worked on the projects in
some capacity would have had to keep the
conspiracy a secret
in his 2006 book the seven secrets of
how to think like a rocket scientist
lungusky suggests that given how
complicated it would be to fake such a
project it might actually be easier to
just go ahead and do the moon landing in
the first place
so if you don't believe the us
government this writer is saying let's
look at some other sources how do we
know those sources are real well we have
some names to look into to independently
verify it we've got this rocket
scientist we have the name of this
german observatory
we could look into and verify these
statements it's not just one guy
asserting that there's goblins on the
moon it's someone saying here are some
non-nasa sources that can confirm that
americans landed on the moon be careful
out there
it's a wild world of people who want to
bend your brains and turn you against
your neighbors
use your brain your heart and your
reading skills to fend them off as you
develop your principles
you've got this readers
you can learn anything
dave it out